bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france la fin du masque
obligatoire en primaire dans 47
départements c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise décision selon vous
une bonne nouvelle surtout une bonne
nouvelle pour les enfants en tout cas
les ensembles la moitié de la france
malheureusement notre moi qui ai
toujours sous contraintes très fortes du
masque et oui les enfants retrouvent une
capacité de respirer son gène il
retrouve une capacité à mettre des
lunettes parce que c'était impossible
avant et de la buée sur les lunettes il
retrouve une capacité à détecter les
émotions de leurs camarades à voir leurs
sourires à voir leur joie ou leur peine
et d'adapter le comportement en fonction
de ça il retrouve aussi leurs
enseignants retrouvent la capacité de
voir la réaction des enfants à
l'enseignement qu'il aurait procuré donc
évidemment c'est une très bonne nouvelle
c'est une très bonne nouvelle que nous
attendions depuis longtemps et pour
laquelle nous sommes mobilisés depuis de
longs mois depuis le mois de novembre
partir du moment où les petits ont été
contraints de porter le masque entre 8 à
10 heures par jour c'est comme vous le
savez une grande partie des enfants
arrivent à l'école parfois l'accueil de
latin et en partage vers 18h à 18h30 en
fin de journée de 10 heures par jour
avec une petite pause pour le déjeuner
masqué contrat est fort c'est donc
évidemment c'est un soulagement et un
retour à la liberté exprimé d'ailleurs
très fortement par les enfants et pour
les enseignants a selon vous c'est une
bonne nouvelle également
au oui je pense que pour les enseignants
c'est une bonne nouvelle également on
les a mis dans une position très
inconfortable
parce que
les vois bien les effets très négatifs
du masque sur les enfants
voilà ils ont eu un développement de
peur très important par rapport à ce que
biden a fait peur à toute la population
et du coup on a décidé de prendre des
mesures le quoi qu'il en coûte il est
pas seulement financier il est
psychologique et notamment sur des
petits en plein développement et c'est
contre cette approche là
ces assemblées et contre cette approche
là courage et votre avis sur le
protocole sanitaire en primaire qui
change dans dix autres départements il
consiste à tester tous les élèves d'une
classe en cas de contamination et à les
renvoyer à la maison que l'état positif
est ce que c'est viable cette solution
d'abord je pense que on est tout à fait
d'accord qu'il faut maintenir les
classes ouvertes c'est l'extraordinaire
priorité ça fait d'importants ensuite je
pense qu'il revient à chaque parent de
dessiner si l'enfant peut être testé
en fonction de l'utilité de ces tests si
ça permet de voir qu'en fait il ya
simplement un cas isolé car comme vous
le savez des petits enfants ne se
contaminent pas entre eux ou très très
peu il reçoit des contaminations par
l'eisa but est donc si ça permet encore
de conforter cet état de fait alors
peut-être que certains parents
accepteront les tests mais je pense que
c'est la responsabilité de chaque parent
parce que la centaine d enfants c'est la
responsabilité des parents et
l'instruction c'est la responsabilité de
l'école chacun son métier à chacun sa
place alors la responsabilité des
parents mais qui peuvent aussi refuser
de faire tester leurs enfants dans ce
cas celui ci sera considéré comme
positif au qu'ovide est-ce que ça sent
quand même extrême est-ce que selon vous
cela constitue un moyen de pression sur
les parents
peut-être peut-être aujourd'hui les mots
les parents sont appelés habitué aux
moyens de pression terrible mais on l'a
vu à plein de niveaux lyon dimanche au
niveau des accents donc je taquin déjà
pris ses dispositions
oui c'est certainement un moyen de
pression à les parents s'adapteront
encore une fois mais il faudrait que
voilà cette manière de faire s'arrête un
jour et puis que on en revienne à une
approche partagée toutes ces
problématiques parce que
rendre le masque obligatoire aux enfants
du collège depuis un an et quatre mois
en aurait trois mois pour les lycéens et
11 mois pour les petits enfants de
l'école c'est une mesure qui est
terrible et on a
je dirais souligné les prétendus
avantages par rapport à la lutte contre
la famine mais on s'est bien gardée
d'analysé il des conséquences négatives
très négative très néfastes sur la santé
psychique physique des enfants et
qui nous avons demandé dès le mois de
novembre une étude à bilan coût
avantageux faire maintenant et nous
l'avons demandé parce que c'est le bon
sens premier mais l'om est ce la demande
et aussi dans la vie du mois d'août 2000
var la défenseure des droits la demande
et par écrit par un courrier du 18
novembre 2020 connaisseur des
démobilisés de l'éducation nationale des
députés ont écrit dans ce sens et il n'y
a toujours rien un an et demi après
avoir commencé un masque et 11 mio ni le
gamin il y a toujours rien
aujourd'hui la décision
blessés l'image dans certains
départements et les prises sur un taux
d'incidence kid s mais les conséquences
sur la santé des enfants on s'en fiche
toujours gare du mans avouez que c'est
quand même extrêmement choquant et nous
n'acceptons toujours pas cet état de
fait parce que avec cette décision
assure que la méthode qui amène à cette
décision bah on peut remarquer des
enfants sur un claquement de doigts
parce que voilà c'est le fait du prince
c'est le fait d'un gouvernant en dehors
de ce fameux cette fameuse analyses
coûts avantages qu'on doit faire pour
des enfants se trouvaient des petits
pour terminer ce sera intéressant de
vous entendre aussi sur l'extension du
pass sanitaires
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
mesure qui peut être adapté aux moins de
12 ans
ça voudrait dire que l'on considère que
le vaccin est adapté aux moins de 12 ans
et à mon avis il en est hors de question
à notre niveau je vais plutôt parlé à
titre personnel parce que notre
collectif s'est pas prononcé là dessus
on est vraiment focalisée aujourd'hui
sur le masque abandonnés ou quoi que
nous allons former très prochainement à
un recours devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour exiger que ce
gouvernement
sa fille dans quoi avantage systématique
en temps réel pour permettre de décider
si oui ou non il faut masquer les
enfants et pour décider si oui ou non il
faut enlever ce masque et on devra faire
la même chose on devrait faire la même
chose parce qu'on est un état libre et
démocratique avec des buts en avantage
sur l'essai de la vaccination c'est
évident
merci beaucoup à vous une école allende
et je rappelle que vous êtes
coordinateur du collectif parents
d'intéressant